so you've been in this filmmaking game
for well over a decade because she said
you were making films even as young as
seven right because your dad was in the
industry what do you think the future of
filmmaking will be like 10 to 20 years
from now what do you see you know DVD
market obviously collapsed took a lot of
jobs with it and in 20 years 20 years
yeah I mean I just wonder what its gonna
be like in a year you know I mean I've
been talking to guys I work with you
know multiple distributors and I've been
talking to a lot of them recently about
stuff like this cuz they're you know
everyone's freaking out you know and I
remember and I'm talk about indie
distributors I don't know as far as like
you know bigger indie like IFC or
Magnolia I'm not talking about the big
indie you know or the or Sony or
anything I'm talking about like the
really indie distributors i remember in
2007 one of them told me that a good
selling DVD was 3,000 copies you know if
they sold three thousand copies then
they've made their money back and a
little bit more now it's 300 copies and
and a lot of their movies do like 50 to
100 copies it's like I can't imagine you
know we're kind of movie for a year I'm
cells like hundred copies I mean you get
a hundred youtube views in a couple
seconds you know with the right video
and you know and then you know another
company did they're not going to do DVD
anymore they're like you know what we're
just gonna do strictly you know the
internet or cable which for somebody
like me so I don't even have the
internet you know so I basically
watching movies I have no idea how it's
going to try because watching movies for
me in a small town sucks because I only
rented from the video stores who used to
have ten now we have none we only have
red box and their movies suck and you
know you get like 30 you know toy of
choice of like 30 films and he can't
even like look at the back of the DVD so
my whole way of viewing movies has
gotten changed so much i would i would
run a movie based on the back of the
because that really kind of would break
or sell the movie and when I would do
that ninety-five percent i would say of
what I rented turned out to be good
because I knew how to judge that way now
it's the opposite ninety-five percent of
why i watch it's almost to the point
where i only want to watch movies
anymore because i don't really get the
judge it before I you know you know I
base it this long little image from the
front you know when I rent and who knows
how long red box is going to be around
if everything goes to the internet you
know so I don't know I'm actually really
freaked out about that I mean it seems
like people's attention spans are too
short you know like it reminds me of
some of these futuristic movies where
you're watching you know they would show
i'm trying to think of what moving it
was a minority report I don't know what
it was but um maybe it was a gamer
anyways I can't rember the movie but I
swear there's been multiple movies were
like they'll show somebody watching 20
channels at once you know 20 different
team monitors and that actually seems
like what people do nowadays it seems
like they're close to that so I don't
and and that means I don't see how
anybody's going to want to sit through a
movie anymore I mean I went and saw Sin
City last night and there was four
people in the theater that just came out
I saw expendables 3 on opening night and
there was six people in the theater in
hollywood at the dome you know I mean I
know there's certain movies that are
doing well but it's like I was looking
around the past few movies I've been
doing on Mike how are these places going
to keep in business you know I mean I
know there's money still being made but
it's like for how big how much bigger
the population is the money has not gone
up with it you know I mean and that
means a lot of people a large percentage
of people are not going to the movies
like they used to be and as far as at
home I mean you know people start
watching something I see a lot of people
review my stuff they're like oh I
watched 30 seconds I don't want to watch
it but I'm going to talk about it
anyways and that's the kind of people
that live in today's world they don't
yeah everybody's sewn to themself I
don't think anybody wants to invest two
hours into a movie of something somebody
else did
and for how self-centered people are
today I don't actually see movie is
existing in 20 years I don't see how it
actually could at the rate we're going
so who knows what the phone business is
going to be like in 20 years it's
probably gonna be 20 channels would look
at me or the news I mean who wants to
spend two hours invested in something
that's not them we're 60 look at me
generation you know and and nothing
sells any more people pirate movies like
crazy they don't think it's worth
anything you know a thousand people
spend a hundred million dollars over the
course of three years making a movie and
people think they can just rip it off
you know I mean so what does that say
about where you know the industry is
going on I don't know it's scary that's
one reason why I'm trying to pump out as
many movies as I can right now or work
as much as I can because I think that it
could possibly completely die I mean you
know then again the world could explode
so who knows seeing how that could
happen tomorrow
you